mom a nostalgia critic guy remember it
so you don't have to you hear it all the
time from people summer movies aren't
what they used to be nobody makes them
like they used to anymore well in some
respects they're kind of right in the
grand history of cinema
we've both visually and with character
push the boundaries of what can be done
some of these Marvel's are so incredible
that you could argue will never
recapture it again but that's not really
what I'm talking about what I'm talking
about is people who grew up in the 90s
saying that they don't make summer
movies like they used to
bull-fucking-shit a lot of people forget
there was a dark dark dark time in our
history where summer movies were just
expected to suck now again I'm talking
specifically about summer movies good
films came out around award season and
yes there are a long list of summer
films in the past they're terrible then
they're terrible now but honest to god
there was a period of time when
audiences just accepted the fact that
every summer we were gonna get something
that was really stupid and most likely
we're not going to enjoy instead of
having movies like say the Avengers
Hunger Games the lego movie and once in
a while a transformers for for a while
every movie we got was transformers for
that's right good summer movies were the
exception they rarely happened and yeah
some films were just underwhelming not
the worst but didn't leave much of an
impression on you but hey that still
counts is not a good movie - I remember
this Dark Age so well I can't even
pinpoint the exact years it happened
1996 to 2001 now to best understand why
this is it's best to look at the films
they came out prior and after a little
before 1996 we made an amazing discovery
CGI with films like Jurassic Park
Terminator 2 and Forrest Gump we were
suddenly realizing that we had a tool
that can make us see whatever we wanted
to see even the greatest effects of the
past had some limitations but now if you
could imagine it it could exist but
sadly like the discovery of anything new
the excitement of one element often
overshadows the other important ones for
example when Super Mario Brothers came
out nobody care what the story was
we were just so excited to see something
so groundbreaking and new now since then
games have gotten a lot more complex and
interesting but that's because the
novelty of what Super Mario Brothers
brought us has worn off it's still a
good game but obviously we create
something new and challenging thus we
need to focus back on those essential
elements again games now have
interesting characters fascinating
stories and incredible effects to make
them much more interesting games the
exact same thing could be said for CGI
and film once we knew anything was
possible we exploited it and I mean
really exploited it suddenly every movie
was a disaster film twister Independence
Day we had to asteroid movies and to
volcano movies the exact same year and
guess what all of them had little to no
story the most basic of cookie cutter
stereotypes and the star of the film was
always the effects explosion storms lava
you name it but the audience was so
excited because we've never seen effects
like this at the time now back then they
were seen as really good but on top of
that the action could be a lot faster
you didn't need stuntmen you could just
green-screen it all the close calls were
made a lot closer because you could
digitally make it look like they really
were
however years later they're mostly
really dated leaving us now not only
with unconvincing effects but no
interesting character a story so there's
really no reason to watch them outside
of giving a giggle about how dated they
are there was also an emphasis to tone
down the muscle-bound action hero and
make them more like the everyman not a
bad idea but again they want to put more
attention on the effects than on the
characters so they went for the easiest
art that was already dated from the 80s
the geek oh not the funny geeks like
what you see today I'm talking Big Bang
Theory geek blackface the geeks that
actually have no idea what a geek is
they just sort of gave them glasses and
have them do something silly sometimes
and boom geek Coffee time cup a cup of
coffee cup of coffee she know this arc
was so easy because hey the main stars a
geek if he saves the day he's already
overcoming something because he's a game
and he never does anything cuz he's a
geek but by yeah these characters were
terrible stuttering Jeff Goldblum
awkward Elijah
would divorcing bill paxton jeff
goldblum again and of course Matthew
fucking Broderick that's a lot of fish
God the heroes that we used to look up
to like our comic book icons well they
were being represented by spawn and
Batman and Robin
because who cared they were just
stopping crime they weren't running away
from a tornado or an asteroid a guy
wearing tights wasn't a big deal sinking
the Titanic was a big deal and seeing
how that was the highest-grossing movie
of all time you bet your ass there were
a lot more disaster films that came out
and when I say disaster I mean both
literally and figuratively
you want know why these films aren't so
inspiring and don't hold up any more
because these movies aren't about heroes
they're about survivors and don't get me
wrong sometimes in life you just need to
survive it's totally understandable but
when everything fucking everything is
centered around just don't die you're
not inspiring people to do anything
greater and these films demonstrated
that Godzilla lost world speed to lost
in space everything was a repeat of a
formula we were already way too familiar
with and they sucked so hard remember
the film men in black it was a good film
right it was funny it was clever it was
well-written but when that movie came
out everybody was treating it like it
was the Second Coming everybody was
shocked holy shit a summer film that
could be smart and clever what the fuck
don't get me wrong it's a decent flick
but back then decent was amazing
anything that was clever creative and
most of all knew was extremely rare it
was a gigantic hit with critics and
audiences talking about it a lot and
yeah once in a while we could get a good
summer flick like face off or mask of
zorro but there was still pretty few and
far between and the absolute worst part
of it is we just accepted it we didn't
make a big deal
we didn't demand movies be better we
just sort of shrugged and walked out we
have more important things in our lives
why should being challenged by art be
one of them so you might be asking
yourself what happened to get summer
movies back on track well a few things
one was the Internet
whereas before you got feedback from
focus
groups which aren't the most reliable
and critics who offer good points of
view but many would argue don't always
represent the everyman suddenly we were
getting feedback directly from the
viewer and it wasn't just word-of-mouth
everyone could post in a forum how much
they liked or disliked a film and with
great speed two films like Bruno and
after Earth were said to be destroyed by
the Twitter effect having a strong
first-day opening but word spreads so
fast that it tanked before the weekend
was over suddenly people could discuss
in front of the world why a film was
good or bad and Hollywood can take
better notes remember when the turtles
were gonna be aliens you can think the
internet for fixing that though Fichtner
still would've rocked on top of that
because we were getting so bored of the
exact same thing Hollywood tried to do
something a little different the exact
opposite films like The Matrix and The
Sixth Sense were coming out which
offered interesting twists and ideas
that weren't in summer movies prior
comic book films like x-men and
spider-man suddenly weren't just punches
and catchphrases they took time to show
emotion in turmoil more arthouse movies
were getting attention again partly
because of new media and then there were
just weird ideas like Pirates of the
Caribbean and Shrek they were strange
and odd but by god we just saw so much
of the same thing we were praying for
strange and odd the first fully CGI
movie came out launching Pixar movies
that had child-friendly ideas every year
and they made money child-friendly money
makers that was unheard of at the time
and then of course there was a gigantic
risk called Lord of the Rings an
expensive film trilogy that was all
being shot at the same time I was going
to be released one a year that was a
fantasy a fantasy those were box-office
bombs in the past but all of these films
were doing something that the films of
the past five years didn't do think they
thought about character they thought
about story they thought about what
wasn't being done in theaters anymore
and they made those elements the stars
again as opposed to the effects which is
not to say a la them didn't have a big
effect but they were no longer the focus
as you'd expect all of these were big
hits and they put together this
brilliant idea that maybe good
characters and good story equals good
movies and maybe good movies could be
whoa
a lot of producers saw what was going on
and tried to plan their films
accordingly true some of the trilogy's
didn't work like The Matrix didn't
pleased them many nor did the Pirates
films but then you have something like
the Marvel Universe this isn't just a
trilogy this is a series of films all
tied together do you know how much time
effort and planning has to go into that
it's hard enough to get one movie off
the ground but a continuing story with
dozens of directors writers and
producers all having to be on the same
page you better be damn sure this is
going to work thus there's a lot more
commitment to it and even the films that
aren't that great still aren't as bad as
those previous five years
yeah Iron Man 2 wasn't so hot but it
tried a lot harder than steel yeah the
Hulk wasn't that great but it wasn't the
Hulk
the focus is where it should be even if
it isn't always done spectacularly that
being the identifiable strong and
different characters we haven't seen
before on the big screen a raccoon in a
tree are our heroes now a fucking yellow
block and touch people's hearts a team
with just a bow and arrow can inspire a
revolution these are all characters that
never would have flown in that previous
five years true most of its based on
existing material and I've done an
editorial on that as well but at least
they're giving unique spins and
interpretations while the subjects have
been done the way they're being done has
some interesting variations now
characters can think about their actions
they can show their emotions they can
inspire heroism and clever ideas there
are no longer exceptions to the rules
good is the new good so the two things I
want you to take from this is one be
fucking grateful so Captain America
changed a few things what do you want a
shot by shot remake of psycho so they
made a hobbit three would you rather
have alien for it's fine to point out
when a movie sucks but don't act like
they're the majority anymore because we
went through five fucking years of that
no matter how much you hate something
now guaranteed they would have done it
worse in that time period too I think
everything will always go through pizza
valleys even art who knows what the next
generation will be inspired to create
and what they'll inspire for the next
generation to create as well well he had
a similar low point
in our future and when we do it's
important to realize that good and
creative ideas will always come back
because hey when our main characters are
looking more like this and less like
this there's still a lot of people out
there want to give us something pretty
awesome
I meant Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to